hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey I'm Brad Chandler one
of our top of Warren tiers on patreon is
whatever video we were you guys request
the patrons this is a video podcast so
there's no editing there we must
definitely do and put up on YouTube and
today comes from Andrew Hayes who
specifically said and I'm so happy I got
Brianne here as I started trying to get
Brianne to be in what's what's happening
where we laughing do you like screen
shot it for you no no no I got something
else I got something else I said I'm
trying to get Breanna bran to get I said
I'm trying get Brandon Chandler to guest
star on the podcast and then he said
that would be awesome she could do it
I'm such a huge fan and this isn't easy
to talk about topic where none of us
made notes because this is so easy to
just spit ball you know just let it all
out we don't have to watch it all what
we're saying this is gonna be easy it's
about art versus the artist she you know
Andrew said I think if you guys become
you guys talked about separating the art
for the artist is I'd love to hear your
thoughts on that especially there
everything going on with Bohemian
Rhapsody and green book during award
season we have Rihanna here a female
presence who's just so you know
diversify it supposed to just two dudes
talking about this and I'm gonna tell
you guys right now always separate the
art from the artists so go watch Woody
Allen's films Roman Polanski's made some
good movies I'm totally lying by the way
[Laughter]
all are its is this is actually a really
tough because it's like this funny thing
is you could talk about this topic and
it could get you in a lot of trouble
just talking about the topic yeah a big
reason for that is that nobody there is
no agreeable rubric for this question
no there isn't and and sometimes I feel
like the the safest bet to start with is
saying that sometimes you got to take
something like this especially a little
bit case-by-case depending on the
situation but then it's like there are
some things where what what do we
perceive as forgivable what do we
perceive as like okay well with enough
time and enough contrition we can let
them come back into the spotlight and
then a lot of this also has to deal with
the idea of we kind of worship our
culture sort of worship celebrities in a
lot of ways as something more than the
average person also I don't know where a
good jumping-off point is our Kelly
all right Kelly it's Chris Pratt's go to
the ball Kate's my case we're gonna
dissect them Aziz Ansari are the judge
with I don't think it's cool how so many
people are already trying to make a
comeback so soon I don't think that is
appropriate like louis c.k popped in my
head I heard like I heard a few minutes
of that actually and I he's already
joking about like no one's gonna book me
did it I was getting the crowd laughing
based off of his past discretions and
I'm like there's no way you've changed
as a human being in this amount of time
like there's just no [ __ ] way you've
changed I think that's one of those show
me the money situations like show me how
you've changed yeah what have you done
how have you helped your your previous
victims in a way that you could like
help them yeah there's some things
obviously you can't do and you can't
like connect with people but like how
have you done anything to change
properly demonstrated you know and some
people are just so quick to forgive too
you know there
yeah some people are so some people
don't see the problem which is like kind
of the weirder part about it
well that's the thing is this stuff that
we love and the people who make it are
very easy to get attached to and they
feel emotional voids which makes this
whole debate much harder to me in a
broad sense because think about like we
all derive is emotional and somewhat
spiritual meaning from the art that we
care the most about and for some people
you know if that's your favorite person
and I guess depending on your
disposition it's just gonna be hard to
not be in denial about that which you
know I don't support that way of
handling these things but I do recognize
that this does present a strange
conundrum for everybody you know and
yeah I mean this is fascinating because
yeah the argument becomes when is it
time and I'm like I don't I don't know
that that needs to be the argument at
all right now yes there's still so much
wrong that's happening and a lot of the
focus also goes on when can they have a
comeback and it doesn't really go on you
know supporting the victims who have
suffered consequences we support people
that have been hurt exactly like
especially them in the movie industry
talk of these things a lot of the people
who are affected are actresses or
aspiring female creators and and then we
don't ever try to like well let's try to
give them a chance or like what what are
the things they suffer with or what are
the art they've try creating that they
were limited I'm putting out there
because of the fact that they were
abused you know we don't ever go in that
direction we immediately go to what is
reconciliation gonna happen for this
person I'm like well I don't think that
was the time to talk about like I think
that's what everyone bryan cranston came
out and he was like we should be
thinking about forgiveness and I'm like
oh sure I don't think right now is the
time we should be talking about
forgiving this person though you know
I'm really fascinated by that part of
this argument just because I totally get
why that should not at all be the focus
but it does naturally seem to be just an
aspect of the situation and if we're all
gonna be discussing it all the time I
don't altogether think it's
inappropriate to wonder
but I do think that you've got to be
tactful in recognizing who you are what
position you're in where are you where
and when you're bringing this idea up
because I am NOT of the mind that I mean
all these crimes are different you know
everybody who we have in our recent
cultural consciousness of having done
something pretty terrible they're all
different and so we're trying to like
we're trying to contain and put rules on
it but I'm like do you can't we all
forget about celebrities is that their
lives include all the mundane
difficulties that ours do to accept we
just view them from afar as these
Titanic figures you know that are held
to this weird standard of perfection and
yet not to say that you know if you [ __ ]
up that doesn't merit consequence but I
think there is also that level of shock
when it's like you idolize these people
as being almost more than human and then
to find out that they're grossly human
is is like a weird thing for people to
handle I think and so yeah then it
becomes well now there's this void of
something that I love when can I fill it
again I think it becomes a little bit
complicated like take Bohemian Rhapsody
for example yes like a big defense that
I've heard for why this film should be
getting the like okay film you know I
mean Raimi is amazing yeah I'll give it
to him you know the thing is with
Bohemian Rhapsody big talk about it is
like Bryan Singer's a credited director
he's gonna be making 20-plus million
dollars off of the success of this film
he just got her Red Sonja had just just
been put on hold now because of the
whole article that was released but the
big talk of it is should Bohemian
Rhapsody be deserving the level the
praise when Bryan Singer is the director
who helmed it and the defense that comes
in as well and this and then this makes
me go to like Roman Polanski for example
or the other countless directors or
producers like Harvey Weinstein
there it's a big collaborative effort
and there's a lot of people involved so
should the film itself be solely
condemned because of the main guy who
helmed it even though there's a lot this
it seems like when everyone's winning
awards
no one's mentioning Bryan Singer okay
but the movie itself still says Bryan
shaker cuz that they they did a great
job on hiding it because the neck it
gets in a complicated territory for like
like I I haven't seen a lot of Roman
Polanski films I did eventually watch I
decided watch Rosemary's Baby around the
time mother came out because I was like
yeah but I don't watch any of the films
he's done in the past recent years I
never saw the pianist yeah I haven't
seen the pianist I haven't seen a lot of
his films and then it goes okay well
then with those people who are supported
Roman Polanski knowing what he did do we
now shut them out I feel like what this
whole debate leads to was just a lot of
questions that I really have very
limited answers and I but I do think
overall know we should have just if you
remove a domino does the rest of it fall
yeah pretty much
and I think generally speaking I don't
think we should remove the the art from
the art like I don't think Roman
Polanski should be my personal belief I
don't think he should be still making
films this is my but my personal belief
Bryan Singer I don't think she'd be
making films anymore like especially
with that I don't know if you guys read
that article
I couldn't even things from the past
about yeah those famously poorly kept
secret yes
like r.kelly yeah do do I think we need
to like burn the material where I sound
that no I don't think we need to like
shelve Rosemary's Baby off of everywhere
or you know like delete American so it's
good it's okay if it was before what
happened well he created this before so
that's right now do I see the [ __ ] up
for saying yes to that
he sucks yeah I get real weird about
things like I'm not gonna go see
spider-man into the spider-verse until
they put a disclaimer for people that
have epilepsy because they did not do
that and I have a friend who had a very
big problem with the movie that was like
so I'm gonna stand my ground and be like
I'm not seeing it until you put that
warning up and then I'll go see it right
that has nothing to do with lower
talking but it was something I was just
thinking that like once it's once it
meets my criteria yeah I mean it's like
a lot of this are very it's all on a
case by case basis and it's like
individuals responses to this like if
you hear that Lois CK audio man there
are people just dying in there and then
you hear then you can read articles of
people who just walk the [ __ ] out of
there you know I'm like right there in
that room you're hearing about the
divided people who just refused to
listen to them left and they're people
who are clapping at all of those jokes
you know well I think there's a there's
there are a lot of things to consider
and I think one of the biggest ones and
I've heard a lot of people touch on this
in discussion is where you are in
proximity like are they still alive are
they still you know at the top of their
game or something like that are you
actively contributing to their
well-being in supporting their arts
somehow because the thing - like
somebody referenced Hannah Gadsby and
the way she takes down Picasso and her
stand-up special like Picasso is a
terrible guy but he's made this timeless
art that we all flocked to me she has to
see I saw a whole static she I think she
flat-out says we just shouldn't separate
the art from the artist yeah and I think
there's then I think there's a fair
argument for that I do think that in
certain contexts the problem is that for
me in that context like with Picasso I
feel like people ought to be aware if
you're gonna take the art in because
clearly this affected the medium in a
significant way so in my mind I'm like I
don't want to burn all of this although
I recognize how problematic it is it's
like I have no idea that's the problem
is ever I think it comes down to a
personal thing and for me I like I I
once went to a protest about a certain
movie it was about on Last Tango in
Paris because somebody was doing a
screening of Last Tango
you know selling tickets for a screening
of Last Tango and the director of that
movie pretty much came out and said we
wanted a natural reaction from our
actress she was not prepared for that
scene and that's like an actual vile
transgression in the text of the movie
itself and that's something where I'm
like yeah even with historical context
to cinema or whatever I don't want to
see that movie anymore I don't want to
support it and then I thought to myself
okay I know which company is exhibiting
this right now so if I'm in a position
or I have to go to this theater for some
reason and I have to pay
then I will actively take it on myself
to go maybe find an organization that
does the opposite of that you know that
supports you know survivors of sexual
assault or something like that
and contribute to that to offset myself
or something like that like that was
kind of the best plan I came up with is
like for the most part when these things
happen it in my conscience it just takes
the art and so now it's like you heard
that stuff about Casey Affleck I was so
excited to see ghost story and now I'm
just kind of like I don't think I'm
gonna watch it just because I don't know
now I just have this taste in my mouth
about that guy yeah and yeah I mean
that's where it comes down for me
honestly is once it's in my brain I'm
aware of it and I'm just not gonna
respond the same way to that art anymore
it's in fact not the same kind of thing
even but a lesser transgression there's
a band I really like and the lead singer
went on Instagram when they were doing a
lot of the gun control protests after
the Parkland shootings and stuff and was
basically vehemently opposed to that and
being very disrespectful towards the
kids especially and that's not the same
kind of offense as sexually assaulting
somebody but I was still like you know I
don't know when the next time I'm be
able to listen to your music is because
this is just ugly and mean-spirited in a
way that I can tell is kind of a part of
your soul yeah and and that's a big
thing too is is there's also the
opposite side another of my favorite
bands you know the lead got into trouble
for flat-out kicking somebody in the
face basically and that was a situation
where I was like you know this is really
shitty of you I don't think that this
says that you hate
a certain group of people or that you
actively seek to destroy I think you
were loaded up and being a bit of a bull
in a china shop and so for this I'm
gonna keep myself aware but I don't
think it's nasty enough that I have to
boycott you forever
you know so I don't know yet for for me
it always comes down to a feeling more
than anything but movies are where it's
hardest to me because there are so many
cogs and not everybody is under the same
position you know some people really
need the work some people don't even
aren't even in the department that's
involved with whoever's making whatever
thing like there's so many people
involved
yeah yeah and so I feel like in the case
of a Bohemian Rhapsody for example yeah
it's like I don't want to support a
Bryan Singer movie now although I
recognize that that movie isn't it's not
like it was his story that he came up
with that he is authoring that he is the
creative voice of this is the queen the
story so in a sense I'm kind of like
well I get that this is not just his
thing if this was the usual suspects too
then I'd just be out you know well I
think though that I feel like there's
something weird about if you look at the
entertainment industry as just jobs you
know jobs in itself okay now let's apply
the word job to any other place of
employment if you're going to McDonald's
and then you're like oh [ __ ] this person
was accused and it's pretty much proven
yeah he has raped people would you want
to get a burger from this pretty no what
I mean but why do how come with the
entertainment industry for like Chris
Brown I mean they kind of is that with
chick-fil-a right because they were like
well I'm not gonna exactly the exactly
thing right yeah and I feel like the
same kind of concept should be applied
with the people who work in the
entertainment industry for sure it's
just like Chris Brown it amazes me how
he still works so much like a lot of
people just go that Rihanna theme was
forever ago like guys a lot of other
[ __ ] has happened with Chris Brown
it's that Rihanna [ __ ] man like a lot of
multiple accusations and demanding
violence
it's just read up on it even very
recently and you know a lot of the
things that people come down to you as
well are the whole it is sent until
proven guilty argument you know which I
feel like my favorite smoke and mirrors
always come a lot of the times is just
way different than actual court yes well
and our the way we discourse especially
nowadays is so accelerated and so hyper
intense in a way I feel like everything
is it's harder to have a discussion
nowadays I feel like cuz I feel like
there's a pressure to know how you feel
right away and to just be on the page
and I don't know I don't I don't
necessarily disagree with the sentiments
it's like yeah I feel like you should
all these people responsible for sure
but I think what it does to the
discourse is fascinating because I think
a lot of people who don't need to hate
each other over the art kind of get to
that place because social media is just
a terrible place to talk about issues
like these you know I mean my thing
though would the whole and it's like the
innocent until proven guilty thing
really struck a nerve for me when it
came to who's the guy who host talking
dead when that when it came to that like
when I heard about whatever that
investigation was and everyone was like
it isn't until proven guilty like do you
how many criminals have gotten away just
because clearly killed her child yeah
but there's not enough evidence to
convict her just like kind of like the
Adnan Syed life story for for whatever
that podcast was and it's like it's like
you can't yes we we really do believe he
killed some women but there's not enough
evidence to convict him
so therefore technically innocent yeah
so he's innocent no right to judge and
I'm like
oh gosh I mean like almost every
murderer who has been convicted and
found guilty there's a long time where
there wasn't enough evidence but we all
[ __ ] you it's like Al Capone like we
all know that guy's a bag which everyone
knew that it's just well we need the
right evidence the point is it's that
black-and-white thinking I am very much
opposed to against in a lot it's listed
when there's like so much presented
already and we're women especially don't
that whole thing we're like women want
their 15 seconds of fame or whatever I'm
like yeah I don't really know what
positive fame does that really get you
know yeah I mean speaking from
experience I definitely don't want
people looking at me like ever so in
regarding certain things and so it's
just like I would never want to do that
unless I felt I needed to in order to
make the story more add more to this
story what's happening was there anyone
was there a service one of these like
for me the big takedown for me the one
that really broke my heart was actually
louis c.k cuz i hailed him as my
favorite comedian was there one of those
celebrities for you that so far that was
like that person i adored and now I just
can't even really listen to them gosh I
really don't think so yeah that guy
regardless I feel like generally
speaking I like no okay Mel Gibson is
one work I have actually been dead
there's a long period of time where I'm
like you know what I'm all full support
for his comeback and it wasn't until
very recently when the whole daddy's
home - because it was you see for me I
was coming on the standpoint of you know
Mel did some fucked-up things and then
he like kind of disappeared for a while
and it was known that he had been you
know at least Cornell I remember his
court-ordered rehab in court-ordered
anger management and and it had an
incident in many years and none Ana Dada
so like maybe he has had enough
contrition or whatever and then it was
actually with this whole Liam Neeson
thing that came up of what he was
talking about for many years ago and I
was listening to I heard several audios
people have commenting on it and one I
came across was from double toasted and
double toasted they brought up how and
those audio recordings sorts his ex-wife
he used the n-word and he said I hope
you get raped by a pack of he said that
and he never melt Gibson never
apologized for Mel Gibson different yeah
train now because he brought up Mel B on
the train so Mel Gibson never apologized
for saying those words and my first
thought was well would anyone have cared
or believed him and then my second
thought was well it doesn't matter he
still should have apologized anyway it
doesn't matter if he's still like yeah
I've seen him do several things with
like Danny Glover since then or Whoopi
Goldberg came out and defended him or
Jodie Foster is openly gay has defended
haven't worked with him since you know
like so but it doesn't matter though
that he that he has like other people
advocating for him and he didn't
apologize for so it was the first time
where I was like oh you know what
and now I'm not and I'm a little bit
conflicted on whether or not I should be
all in support of this guy because he's
[ __ ] made hacksaw rage and he's still
a damn good actor you know and I mean I
think a lot of this has to do with
putting yourself beyond yourself because
the biggest one of the biggest problems
I see with a lot of these issues is that
people don't take the moment to
entertain what the group they don't
belong to who is speaking out has to say
or how they might feel you know it's
like a point you gotta cuz yeah for
people who are like actual survivors of
assaults or sexually all these thing
like they're the that's it's wholly
different they will feel completely much
stronger about this and I will feel
about it yeah it's like with the Liam
Neeson thing for example I mean there's
I think a lot of the natural inclination
for a lot of people is to go well he was
confessing to something he wasn't proud
of from a very long time ago as you know
sort of illustrating the ugliness of
revenge and in a sense I I get it and I
don't hate Liam Neeson now but I also
think it's incredibly valid for at least
the people in the black community I've
heard to be like look this is part of a
culture that has even beyond that point
in that place in the world caused some
really terrible things for us so I think
those people are entitled to feel how
they feel right now because it doesn't
matter when you heard about it you heard
about it when you heard about it and
you're gonna feel it based on that so
even if that happened to him 40 years
ago I don't think we should quote cancel
Liam Neeson but people have a right to
feel the way they feel especially in the
communities he could have affected you
know yeah and I think that is something
that we all need to do better at
entertaining is sort of what is the
counter especially for the victims and
and why might that be
because I think we all forget that the
goal is to kind of be a great humanity
together and learn yeah and I get better
and I feel like it's really easy to
spout off without going okay who was
affected by this and what do they have
to say yeah yeah I don't think we should
I I do I totally believe that people can
change and I totally believe that and
forgiveness absolutely there is there's
a point though where I'm like that that
idea of contrition like how long has it
been
just like when they do the whole thing
about bringing up old tweets of people
like with the Kevin Hart thing we're
like James Gunn no staying the Oscars
James Gunn losing a job it's like what I
don't know see that's a case by case
really is case my kids knows I'm like
well I feel like with James gone that
should have been a discussion I'm like
sure these jokes are gross but come on
Disney you [ __ ] hired him you know
yeah yeah yeah you [ __ ] you knew that
it and say that we Kevin Hart as well
you know and I've heard some people have
been saying like he still should have
apologized even though he's already
apologized he should still apologize
again even retweet retweet is about no I
don't know I mean generally speaking
Breanna what do you do do you think did
you think it's just a case by case
scenario or do you think in general I
think it's always a case by case yeah
obviously like there's that saying the
punishment fits the crime right so like
I don't know when you have these smaller
things like a tweet that I say smaller
it's probably big to people and I
apologize if I have offended someone but
like when you have something like
bringing up old tweets like that has a
different weight than someone who is
sexually abused someone else so yeah so
there's I definitely think everything is
a case-by-case basis in every situation
and it's always for yourself like what
do you feel because we don't have a set
rule of in society like well if you do
this then that's at least three months
of we don't get to see you and then you
can come back we don't have those rules
so I think it has to be obviously up to
you and what you are comfortable with
and I think it's okay like to say to
other people like if someone's like oh
you want to go see this movie this
weekend and I think it's okay for me to
say I'm not really comfortable with
seeing that person in that film so you
go enjoy yourself and I'm not gonna see
that with you know things like that now
and I don't even need to get into why
like or I could just be like I don't
really like this person you have fun
yeah well all right well this is fun I
think we do P I think we solved all of
it we've done is discuss the questions
mm-hmm yeah people need to disappear
sometimes and just let them disappear
for a long time with a real apology and
focus more on the victims guys what do
you think should you separate the art
from the artist you have the answers
YouTube commentators and Andrew Hayes
thanks so much for requesting this buddy
this was a subject where you have to be
mindful of what you're saying at all
times
and I appreciate the challenge of
putting our voice out there and I know
this video will be met with no dislikes
only votes the entire time so Andrew
thank you for allowing us to have some
controversy in our lives
yeah very calm and collected controversy
yeah I would never having to be wary of
certain things to bring up it's just
great exactly how we're articulate
subscribe you do a fun thumbnail pose
whoa-ah humor subscriber nation click
that notification Bell check us on
patreon and follow Brienne Chandler you
still miss boobies on there miss movies
yep miss miss underscore movies on
Instagram and you can find her at your
local Cathedral helping out with the
homeless children yeah I do I'm at the
food banks regularly so it's feeding
herself see you guys